nous sommes au théâtre de dix heures je
suis à côtés d'alban livanof un comédien
qui vient de chez nous j'ai un peu peur
parce que c'est un improvisateur qui est
très doué il s'est toujours rebondir et
faire des choses un petit peu
surprenante alors je ne vois pas très
bien ce qu'ils faisaient et m'a dit
qu'il était très inspiré 7,8 frère
t'inquiète pas on fait les buy on est
largué dans les sketchs ou big raf des
blagues t'inquiète pas on fait notre
petit beurre oui
merci beaucoup de me recevoir et de
m'accorder une petite interview tv fil
78 je trouve ça super cool c'est vrai
que moi aussi je fais du 78 donc par
rapport à mes racines ça me resservent
vachement je me sens soutenu ça me fait
vraiment du bien
voilà tu es venu voir moins de man show
ça t'a plu j'espère que ça plaira aux
spectateurs téléspectateurs auditeurs
et tu vois là bas on se retrouve
peut-être juste après pour une interview
si vous le voulez bien
vous l'avez vu alban ivanov est un
comique cet humoriste originaire de
versailles a connu l'improvisation dès
son plus jeune âge évidemment alban a
fréquenté déclic théâtre où il a
rencontré pappis directeur artistique de
la compagnie trappistes l'homme a aidé
le jeune artiste à construire son
premier one man show passé de
l'improvisation au texte suscite
quelques difficultés à pied un jour
m'avait dit ça très justement il m'avait
dit si tu regardes bien tout les intros
que tu as fait les matchs d'impro que tu
as fait dessus tu as été acteur auteur
et metteur en scène donc c'est juste en
fait de retranscrire tout ce qu'on a
fait à l'oral à l'écrit
tous les mardis alban se produit au
théâtre de dix heures scène parisienne à
la recherche de jeunes talents son
premier spectacle se situe à mi chemin
entre stand up et interprétation de
personnages alban us d'un franc parler
et ne craint pas les critiques ces
propos crus il les assume à l'image de
l'acteur porno qui s'adresse à andré un
ami très intime mais c'est sûr c'est pas
évident a tourné trois films journée oui
c'est dur quoi je tenais je parlais avec
un prix défini éhonté qui emplit qui en
ferait la ville pauvre conne
si je vois que ça des roches quelqu'un
ou
ou que ça le fait réagir et ben c'est
pareil c'est pour montrer une certaine
manière je suis conscient de 2,2 ce que
je fais voilà j'assume j'assume parmi
les personnages d'albon certains
reconnaîtront vénère un rappeur à la
rime acerbe née au comedy club
albon reviendra au théâtre de dix heures
dès le mois de septembre en attendant
vous pourrez retrouver les mardis 10 et
24 juillet julie galibert une autre
artiste lié à déclic théâtre